that's what we're going to see this this
uh winter when we run out of of of uh
sufficient uh uh fossil fuels and some
people are gonna start freezing we will
be much much more worried about cold
waves than heat waves but that's not how
the media presented that's why we're in
a trouble is it really the focus on
global warming as global warming or is
it also a little bit to focus on global
warming as kind of this ideological
struggle that fulfills almost an
emotional need for for many people much
more than an environmental need why is
there no you know manhattan-like project
into nuclear fusion or into nuclear
energy in general there are many tools
would have our disposal that could
really help with global warming but
sometimes i'm exaggerating here slightly
but sometimes i almost feel like that
some might don't want to go global
warming fully away because they kind of
poured all the heart and soul into it
but now by the way something i think we
partially also see with kobe it kind of
bleeds over into a you know a cultural
moral problem and these strike me is
much more difficult to overcome
[Music]
hello everyone i'm extremely pleased
today and privileged i would say to sit
down with bjorn lomberg who i regard as
the world's foremost commentator on
environmental and sustainability matter
matters
in the best possible sense and ralph
schollhammer a journalist who's been
working in europe diligently covering
such ill-covered topics as the dutch
farmer's protest and i recorded a video
earlier this week with michael yawn who
is a war correspondent and a journalist
who's also been covering the farmer's
protests and he made a variety of
prognostications about the dismal
prospects of the coming fall and i
thought i would talk to bjorn and ralph
in some detail
about global issues particularly with
bjorn because as i said he's
incredibly well versed in such matters
and then with ralph more particularly
about
the rising wave of protest around the
world canada the u.s europe while in
other countries as well and see if we
can bring some clarity to the issue so
i'll start with uh bio of bjorn and
ralph so that people know who i'm
talking to and then we'll jump right
into the discussion
ralph schollhammer is an assistant
professor
in political science and economics at
webster university
in addition to his teaching and research
commitments
he is a regular contributor to the
public discourse
and has been published in newsweek the
jerusalem post the washington examiner
and the wall street journal
he also hosts his own podcast called the
in which he talks to guests about a wide
range of issues from roman history to
contemporary culture in the western
world as well as global geopolitics
dr bjorn lomborg
one of the world's foremost political
thinkers researches and this is the
truth the smartest ways
to do good
with his think tank the copenhagen
consensus
he has worked with hundreds of the
world's top economists and seven nobel
laureates
to find and promote the most effective
solutions to the world's greatest
challenges from disease and hunger to
climate and education and so if you're
genuinely concerned about
doing your duty to your culture and the
planet bjorn is a great person to know
about to read about and to follow
i think that might be more true of him
than of any
thinker on the
policy front that i've ever encountered
for his work
lomborg was named one of time magazine's
hundred most influential people in the
world he's a visiting fellow at stanford
university's hoover institution and is a
frequent commentator in print and
broadcast media for outlets including
the new york times wall street journal
the guardian cnn fox and the bbc
his monthly column is published in many
languages by dozens of influential
newspapers across all continents
he is also a best-selling author
whose books include
false alarm
how climate change panic costs us
trillions hurts the poor
and
fails to fix the planet bjorn has
discussed that book at some length on my
podcasts among many other places he's
also written the skeptical
environmentalist
cool it
how to spend 75 billion dollars to make
the world a better place which is a
fascinating read
the nobel laureate's guide to the
smartest targets for the world 2016-2030
and
prioritizing development a cost benefit
analysis of the un's sustainable
development goals so welcome to you
bjorn and ralph i'm very much looking
forward to our discussion today and hope
that it will enlighten people as to
the sorry state of european politics
let's say and
the uh
and bring some clarity to the discussion
of the apocalyptic nightmare that seems
to be plaguing us above all else at the
moment
bjorn no doubt you've been watching
what's happening on the european protest
front and with the manufactured energy
crisis and now with the manufactured
food and fertilizer crisis and
so
what do you see happening now and what
do you see coming
it's very hard yes i have been watching
as i think ralph has i mean we both live
here uh in europe uh and i think the
fundamental point is it's really hard to
see what is gonna happen i'm gonna give
you a little bit of background because i
think it's important to sort of
look at why is it we're so dependent on
russian gas and the simple answer is
because we have lots of renewables what
do you get when you have lots of
renewables you get lots of power when
the sun is shining and the wind is
blowing but you have none
when the sun is not shining and the wind
is not blowing and then you need backup
power in
in past times we would get this from
coal now coal emits a lot of co2 so a
lot of the continent has simply got rid
of coal coal fire power plants that's
all overall a good thing partly because
they pollute a lot they actually make
you know kill people through pollutants
but also because they emit a lot of co2
which obviously is also bad and so we've
gone to gas
but we have not delivered our own gas so
europe has lots and lots of shale gas
potential shale gas just like the us
but we have not used it we have to a
large extent been incredibly worried
about shale gas oh shale gas is probably
gonna you know create a lot of
earthquakes or it's gonna pollute the
drinking water all those kinds of
stories that you also heard in the u.s
and again remember it's not that it was
entirely untrue there are some problems
with fracking in the us but
fundamentally fracking has made the us
both much more energy independent and it
has actually reduced dramatically
the of the emissions of the us the u.s
has reduced its emissions more than any
other country in the world over the last
10 years
europe did not do that because we had
cheap russian gas and now we're in this
pickle so fundamentally it's because we
don't like coal we love renewables and
then we need lots of gas and there we
are right now and of course that is
going to make us very very vulnerable to
pressure from putin everybody has been
pointing that out before
well let's let's dig into that a bit
first of all
it was completely obvious that
unidimensional dependence on the
russians for vital energy sources was a
bad strategic idea not not and that's
even the case i would say in some sense
if russia was a clear ally and we
weren't in a war with them because you
don't want your entire economy so
unresilient that you're dependent on a
single source for your fundamental
resource and everyone who had any sense
whatsoever could see that just as
clearly as they could see the daylight
sun and then the second issue here and i
i don't think people do understand this
is that
every energy source has risks so for
example
if you put solar panels on your roof
you pose a risk to the workmen who
install it because they fall off the
roof and you might think well that's
trivial danger but way more people are
killed installing solar panels every
year than are killed by nuclear power
for example and so every
energy source has its risks and you know
i grew up in northern alberta and people
had fracked there for decades no one was
concerned about it in the least and so
then when
everyone started to short out about the
dangers of fracking we all knew people
that i knew knew that that was just
rubbish
but even more importantly if you are
concerned environmentally and there are
some reasons to be concerned
environmentally
you would have to point to the fact that
the americans and their success with
fracking drove their carbon emissions
down 15
i believe and as you pointed out they're
the only industrialized country that has
managed this and so if you were really
concerned about the environment and not
just an idiot communist anti-capitalist
you would note that and you'd think well
this is a lot better than the
alternative which is
high energy prices which are hard on the
poor hyper dependence on the russians as
single source energy um and then
well and then the fact that if you
fracked you if you did don't frack you
have to turn to alternate energy sources
that are going to pollute or leave you
vulnerable now is there is there
anything wrong with that analysis even
from the pro-environmental front
so i think the fundamental point here is
that we were so worried about global
warming that we forgot to realize we
need to be worried about a lot of other
things like for instance being security
dependent on russian gas so look if you
if we had a wonderful co you know
peacefully coexisting world there's
nothing wrong with getting your power
from other places because actually you
know where they can do it most
effectively is probably a better idea
but obviously we don't live in that
world and i think it's been clear for
most people at least for you know decade
or two that putin was probably not our
best ally and so clearly we should have
been more concerned this is what happens
i think this is sort of the step back we
need to take
this is what happens when you only worry
about global warming if global warming
is the only thing on your radar you
obviously forget all the other things
there's a new survey from oecd that
showed of all the ocd countries they
asked adults uh and uh representative uh
a
segment of of adults for all oecd
countries
sixty percent of them believe that it's
likely global warming will lead to the
end of mankind
if you think this is the end of the
world then obviously nothing else
matters
it is not global warming is a problem
yes but it's not by any means the end of
the world and one way to look at that is
you know we've just seen a lot of heat
waves and those are horrible and
remember heat waves are damaging and
they will kill some people they're
definitely dangerous
but
after all they will probably kill you
know in the order of a couple of
thousand people remember every winter we
probably see about three to six hundred
thousand people die from cold in europe
we don't have a good sense of proportion
if we're only focused on the and it's
actually a lot more so 100 200 000
people actually die from heat across the
year but forget the many many more that
die from coal and that's what we're
going to sorry that's what we're going
to see this this winter when we run out
of of of uh sufficient uh uh fossil
fuels and some people are going to start
freezing we will be much much more
worried about cold waves than heat waves
but that's not how the media present it
and that's why we're in a trouble
can i jump in real quick here because i
think what bronzer was so interesting
and uh because you mentioned kind of
there is this this focus on global
warming and you think you're right but
could you maybe dissect a little bit
more is it really the focus on global
warming as global warming or is it also
a little bit to focus on global warming
as kind of this ideological struggle
that fulfills almost an emotional need
for for many people much more than an
environmental need what i mean by this
is for example why is there no you know
manhattan-like project into nuclear
fusion or into nuclear energy in general
i think we have and you mentioned this
in your writing so many times there are
many tools would have our disposal that
could really help with global warming
but sometimes i'm exaggerating here
slightly but sometimes i almost feel
like that some might don't want to go
global warming fully away because they
kind of poured all the heart and soul
into it i mean you know in the past
right with acid rain we had the ozone
layer and there was kind of global
action taken to address this because it
was seen as a technical problem but now
by the way something i think we
partially also see with kobe it kind of
bleeds over into a you know a cultural
moral problem and this strike me is much
more difficult to overcome
ralph it might be that to some degree
we're wired
to apprehend the apocalypse and part of
the chronic psychological
problem of mankind is where to put hell
in the apocalypse and satan for that
matter
properly
and i think we're apocalyptic because
everybody knows in their heart of hearts
that
everything comes to an end and we have
to contend with that our lives come to
an end the lives of those we love come
to an end civilizations come to an end
and we also know that there's an
association between the morality of our
actions and the likelihood of a
cataclysmic end and part of the utility
of a functioning religious enterprise is
to help us manage those apocalyptic
visions without them contaminating
everything we do
because it is hard and bjorn pointed to
this if covid is a disaster then it's
the only thing you should focus on and
if
environmental degradation is a disaster
then it's the only thing you should
focus on but
it isn't the only thing you should focus
on and one of the great advantages of
bjorn's books and works and and and
institute is that
he's done what politicians are supposed
to do which is to take a look at the
broader context and to say well what's
the complete list of our problems
and how do we intelligently wade our way
through the whole set i mean when we
panicked about kovit we blew our supply
chains apart and however many millions
of people we might have saved with the
kovid reaction and i'm very dubious
about any of those claims god only knows
how many people we're going to doom now
because of supply chain disruptions and
communication disruptions between say
putin and the rest of the world
rest of the world because of kovid
lockdowns bjorn
yeah no i i totally agree i think it's
incredibly hard to imagine that i think
ralph you're you're absolutely right
there is a lot of people who feel that
that you know recycling and all these
things sort of make sense in their life
it's part of the thing that you do to
feel like i'm a good citizen
and and in some ways i i i constantly
try to argue well shouldn't we talk
about how effective this is and and and
i think there is there's some part of
this that we really need to confront i'm
glad we can do that in this conversation
uh just one uh example that i think is
so you know spot on uh and and you'll
probably love this uh uh jordan uh uh a
couple weeks ago as you well know uh
about a billion people are likely to be
starving uh and this winter will
probably be even more because we don't
have enough food one of the ways you
produce food in this world is through
fertilizer fertilizer is what drives it
but of course most fertilizer most
synthetic fertilizer is made with gas
and so when the eu was approached should
we not make more fertilizer for the
world they go oh but that's going to
make us use more gas no i think we'll
not do that there's something morally
wrong about this of saying yeah you know
what you know a couple hundred million
people are gonna start but at least we
didn't use extra gas you know the same
way as the much of the rich world is
saying to the poor world you guys you
know we got rich from using lots of
fossil fuels but you guys you don't
really need that which of course to a
very large extent means leaving them in
poverty and of course they don't
actually accept to do that and so i
think there's a point of ralph to your
your argument of saying this is also a
religion but on the other hand i think
if you're going to converse with people
if you're actually going to have a
a reasonable conversation with them i
think it has to be about the facts so
basically talking about what can you do
how much good will you know cutting a
ton of co2 do how much will it
you know good will it do if you recycle
a bottle how much good will it do if you
get more fertilizer for poor people and
it turns out not surprisingly that most
of the things that we focus a lot on are
basically feel good things they'll do
very little even for poor people and
even in 100 years whereas many of the
obvious things are these slightly boring
things like getting uh you know
people with tuberculosis get them
addressed
remember again tuberculosis is world's
leading infectious disease killer when
there's not covet
but we don't care about it because we
fixed it a hundred years ago in in in
the rich west but there's still lots of
these issues and and likewise just to
put out one more thing um about a
billion people uh so about a billion
school kids have lost on average nine
months because of lockdowns of schools
during covet this is probably the
biggest loss so the world bank uh
estimate that by 2040 when these kids
are now out and actually being
productive their world will be 1.4
trillion dollars less rich every year
because these kids are less
well-educated how is that not our
biggest challenge we'll get back to more
with our guests bjorn lomberg and ralph
schulhammer in just a moment this show
is sponsored by helix sleep getting a
good night's sleep is one of the most
important things you can do for your
health just like your diet and exercise
routines are unique to your body's needs
so are your sleeping habits that's why
helix sleep provides tailored mattresses
based on your unique sleep preferences
the helix lineup includes 14 mattresses
each designed for specific sleep
positions and preferences side sleeper
models with memory foam layers offer
optimal pressure relief stomach and back
sleeper models feature a more responsive
foam to cradle and support your body
plus helix mattresses offer enhanced
cooling features to keep you from
overheating at night don't compromise on
comfort take the helix sleep quiz and
find your perfect mattress in under two
minutes helix mattress ships straight to
your door free of charge try it for a
hundred nights risk-free go to
helixsleep.com jordan take the helix
sleep quiz and get up to 200 off your
mattress order plus two free pillows
that's helix sleep.com
jordan for 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows
well let's answer that why is that not
our biggest challenge and so we'll go
back to the religious issue so if you
configure the apocalypse and hell
properly then you take it upon yourself
to carry a very heavy moral burden and
that burden is to put your life together
and that means to be
productive and generous and honest
and concerned with life more abundant
for everyone and you have to retool your
whole psyche in some sense to aim
towards that and that takes that's
100 dedication and a lifetime of effort
but if you're worshiping at the altar of
a false god let's say what you're
looking for is shortcuts to put yourself
to put yourself in a position where you
have the moral advantage and where you
can claim reputation stakes because of
that and all of this false moral
posturing that comes along with these
shallow analysis is in my psychological
estimation nothing but a narcissistic
trip to replace competence with the
false competence of the machiavellians
and the psychopaths and
because i mean your work struck me so
hard bjorn because i worked on the un
report on sustainable development for
the secretary general i worked on that
for a couple of years and one of the
things that really came to the forefront
for me there were two things three one
is we stupidly overfished and destroyed
the oceans that's a really nasty thing
and we we didn't have to do that the the
second was oh
all the data shows that if you make poor
people rich as fast as possible they
stop polluting and start caring about
the environment so isn't that something
we could make everyone rich and the
planet would be better off and then the
next thing was well
what's the rank order of importance of
our problems and i went back to the un
central agencies authorities a couple of
times the other people who were working
on the report there were many of them
and said well you guys have 200 goals
here or whatever it is
400 or 169. it's like
that's not any goals
goals have to be prioritized
because
you can't do 200 things at a at the same
time and all 200 things aren't of equal
importance and they said well there's a
constituency for each of these goals and
if we prioritize them we'll annoy
someone it's like that's not a good
reason and
and then next we don't have a
methodology for prioritization i thought
well that's a big problem does anyone
and the only one i came across and maybe
you could explain this a little bit the
only one i came across
was you
and so you tackled this problem which i
thought was i really thought that was a
stroke of genius bjorn and if the nobel
prize committee had any sense you would
have been a recipient of the peace prize
for this work because it's signally
important so you want to outline what
you do and what you've concluded so
thank you very much i mean i should just
say what we're doing is not rocket
science and as you point out it's kind
of obvious if you have 169 targets which
is what the u.n had you have no
priorities and so we simply try to work
with some of the best economists across
the world to look at where can you spend
an extra dollar or an extra rupee or an
extra shilling or whatever your currency
is and do the most good this is an
objective question and of course you can
have a lot of conversations about how do
you value different things because
remember you need to
include everything so they're both going
to be economic costs they're also going
to be social costs you know for instance
if you vaccinate someone not only has a
cost from the hospital part of thing but
you also need to take people's time to
get vaccinated maybe they need to get
off work and there will also be
environmental uh you know cost for
instance if you put up a new power plant
not only does it have cost but it will
also
add to more pollution and more co2
emissions you need to include all of
that and likewise there are going to be
lots of benefits both economic social
and environmental benefits now what we
try to do
is to include all of the cost and all of
the benefits and
account them in dollars this is
something economists have done for 30
years and obviously it feels a little
sort of really can you do that you know
how many lives are you going to lose but
remember we do that you know
uncontroversially in many different
contexts uh one obvious places when when
you put out roads uh you decide what
kind of security are you gonna have on a
road uh are we gonna have you know a
heart uh center line so people can't run
into each other it's more costly but it
also saves more lives and governments
around the world make those trade-offs
depending on how many lives you're going
to save and how how costly is it going
to be
that kind of
consequence thinking we put into all of
these issues and then we basically came
out with a list of saying these are the
very best things to do these are the so
so so good things to do and these are
actually the dumb things to do and so we
simply tried to say do the smart stuff
and i appreciate you saying that that
this is something that the nobel
committee should be looking at but i
think you know in some sense it's so
obvious it's not it's not it's not
rocket science but we don't do it
exactly as you say because nobody wants
to offend anyone so we just say
everything is important and we also end
up worrying about the stuff that makes
the headlines which very often is global
warming and other you know
yes problems but perhaps not the most
important ones
well we we also do it because we're lazy
and ill-informed and treacherous because
we want to take the easy moral path
instead of plowing through like let's
say your work and i'd like to point out
by the way to those who are listening
you can argue about the accuracy of cost
benefit analysis because it's hard to
price everything and to value everything
and you can debate about how you might
do that but bjorn who is doing something
closer to rocket science in some sense
than he admits he got teams of
economists together multiple teams to
independently produce
lists of cost benefits
by problem and then he averaged across
the ratings and i know as a
diagnostician and as a researcher that's
how you come up with reliable
calculations and so those are
calculations that could be replicated
and valid calculations and a valid
calculation is one that actually bears
some resemblance to the real world and
so what you did
is in some sense in retrospect
self-evident but it's also very very
sophisticated conceptually and but what
is also so remarkable is that it's it's
a singular attempt
despite the fact that we're jumping up
and down about the coming apocalypse and
everyone's got their panties in the knot
as a consequence of it
no one has sat down and done the
hard-edged economic analysis that you
have done and then you've taken a hell
of a lot of flack for it too because you
end up prioritizing things like well
stopping tuberculosis and feeding
children instead of
what shutting off europe's energy supply
so that we can reduce carbon dioxide and
and patter cells on the back for saving
the planet and you faced an awful lot of
vitriol as a consequence of this too
which i also find unbelievably appalling
because
all of your work is devoted clearly
towards specifying the most good that
can be done in the most efficient
possible manner and why someone would be
attacked for that is that's really a
great mystery where you're obviously
undermining this this very shallow
religious commitment people have to
their apocalyptic pretensions and that's
the primary reason but it's it's also
unbelievably appalling
serbia just well but i think it makes a
lot of sense because you're heretic
right i mean you you in in like you know
in previous times it's like you know
imagine you know you're in like a
fictional island culture and what they
do is every year they throw a virgin
into a volcano in order to get a good
harvest and then you come along and say
wait a moment you actually could get the
good harvest without throwing the virgin
into a volcano there will be many people
who would say but we are used to
throwing that virgin into the volcano
right i think i think we
it's a technical problem but i think a
lot of it and this has been i would
argue foster since the 1960s but it's a
it's a cultural problem so much right
this has been kind of instituted in
education or this idea you know in the
70s it was the new ice age it was all
these kind of things i think this the
consciousness for the do for
environmental doom has kind of been you
know inflicted upon the younger
generations now for at least two
generations and you i think again i
think technically everything you say is
right but maybe you could also speak a
little bit to i mean william northhouse
did get a nobel prize right kind of
talking in a similar direction and i
wonder why is he never in a talk show i
don't know maybe he's a reclusive i
don't know but he's never in a talk show
like he's barely ever quoted so i wonder
i wonder why it is and i think because
he is less outspoken than you are but i
think he would probably also be seen as
a heretic so so it's it's that's why you
see more toonbergs and less less
lomborgs and less um
uh note houses yeah why why we see greta
thunder instead of you on the
international stage is just that's just
maybe she's the virgin we're sacrificing
to the volcano you know so so i i think
it's
you know you're both right and and and
in very
specific sense i think
what you just mentioned about the un
that they didn't want to offend anyone
remember we we basically come out and
say as you said you know we should be
focusing on uh uh on free trade
contraception for women uh uh
vaccinations uh for for a lot
rotaviruses uh you know a lot of these
very very simple things that you can do
a lot about uh tuberculosis food for
kids uh it's also a way to get better
schooling better schooling all these
kinds of very very simple things and and
the reason why they didn't want to
prioritize it was because they did not
want to offend anyone but as you point
out who gets offended well when we put
down some of the you know solutions uh
that people argue for climate change
they're not bad they're just not very
effective some of them are actually bad
and and you know the the thing that
we've just done in europe we'll probably
end up seeing in half a year was very
bad but fundamentally that pisses off a
much bigger segment then you know we
everybody who does tuberculosis think
we're you know the we're the uh what's
the smartest thing since uh sliced bread
uh so it's it's not that there's not
constituents out there that like what we
do all the ones that get up on top think
it's amazing and not surprisingly but
there's just so many more people who are
advocating for the bottom things in that
sense i think it's it's it's more a
question of saying well this is almost a
poll of saying what is it that makes
sense for people what is it the religion
that we make makes us feel like we're
doing something for the world and for
most people it feels much better to be
saving the planet which you
unfortunately are not actually doing
instead of saving some kids lives which
just feels like yeah
you know our prime minister in canada
has just decided to do the same thing to
canadian farmers that that the
netherlands has done to the dutch
farmers he's going to force them because
he likes to use force because he's
saving the planet even though he's not
he's going to force them to reduce their
nitrous oxide output and here get this
man this is something he decided that
he's going to do that without
calculating the ratio of pollution
produced to food produced and so the
provinces and the farmers are pushing
back and saying well how about you judge
our polluting use on the basis of how
much food we produce wouldn't that be
like vaguely reasonable and the answer
from the feds has been no we want an
absolute reduction and that's exactly an
example of this low resolution
narcissistic moralism that is
substituting both for genuine religious
conviction and for genuine knowledge and
i would say our prime minister in canada
he is he if
if it isn't jacinda arden and kamala
harris it's definitely justin trudeau
who are the poster people for this sort
of thinking so so just just on uh very
very briefly
it's a it's a great example of how
economists would approach this
conversation it's basically saying look
there's something nice about this idea
of reducing uh nitrogen uh deposits it
actually you know especially biologists
but also other people like the fact that
there are low
of uh
low fertilizer uh areas you know where
where different kinds of sparse
plantations uh live and and that can be
a nice sort of ecosystem but if you ask
most people how much are you willing to
pay for that so you know the other scent
said is we can't produce as much food we
can't keep our culture uh a lot of
farmers are going to go
bankrupt and of course also that you're
just going to move this nitrogen deposit
to for instance developing countries
instead right exactly then you have to
ask so what's the weighing of these two
things we do that all the time and and
let me just give you this one obviously
when you talk about the speed limit
most people you know if you if you don't
so in the us about what 40 000 people
die on the roads every year mostly
because people uh drive too fast and and
the simple question is well shouldn't
you do something about it if you if you
don't reflect very much people will just
say yeah that number should be zero well
there's a very obvious way to get it to
zero it is to put the speed limit at
five kilometers or three miles an hour
now nobody would get killed but nobody
would get anywhere either so that's of
course why we don't actually do it every
year and every day we decide
all of us
yes i would like to go at a reasonable
speed
and that will end up meaning some people
will die there's a trade-off here now we
can have a sensible conversation do we
want to have uh you know like uh uh
sorry i'm a little unsure where well i
should use miles or a kilometer i'm just
going to go with miles right so okay can
we use 55 kilometers
i didn't do that did i 55 miles or you
know 85 miles and that's a fine
conversation but nobody suggests it
should be zero or three miles an hour
and that's the conversation that we need
to have in all these other things so
when we're talking about nitrogen
deposits of course we all want to have
less rather than more but we also have
lots of other things we want to do we
need to recognize those likely
yeah so okay so i want to return to
something you said and then i want to
talk about economists versus biologists
let's say
so
when i had calculated and this is a
rough calculation and i knew it was
wrong i figured that we'd be facing a
world in the fall in the winter where
150 million people would be starving but
michael yawn
mentioned that it was going to be 1.2
billion that was his estimate and i
thought oh my god
not only is that famine on a level that
we haven't seen probably since the early
60s and then he talked about how famine
multiplies a because once a famine hits
that the governments tend to take
centralized control over food production
and basically appropriate farmers crops
and then the farmers quit growing crops
which is exactly what you'd expect so
not only do you have one billion you
have the stage set for an expansion of
of
of famine and then i thought well and
yawn commented on this as well well what
happens when 1.2 billion people go
hungry and that's going to be well in
the poorest countries
throughout
throughout this the countries that are
most likely as well to push desperate
immigrants towards europe's borders and
the same on the american front and so
not in the fall you know you tell me
again if i'm wrong
if you are right and yawn is right not
only are we going to see
a seventh of the world go hungry in a
serious way like it's already happening
in sri lanka but we're going to see
immigration pressure
human movement pressure on the flanks of
europe and the united states on a scale
that maybe we've never seen
is and how how sure are you that that's
what we're looking at in the in the fall
and winter
so i think there's a couple things uh
first of all we we're starting out in a
in a world where there's already uh uh
some seven or eight hundred million
people that are starving and this is
fairly little to do with the current uh
energy crisis or fertilizer crisis but
it's just the fact of people being poor
uh so again that goes to your general
point of saying look maybe we should get
people out of poverty first but the
second part of this is uh it actually
turns out that when people are really
really poor and really damaged in many
ways for instance uh through starvation
they will not flee because they can't uh
so i i'm not sure that we're gonna see
huge uh uh immigration streams we might
and i think it's useful to start
thinking about uh but i don't have the
data on on whether so so that there's a
you know
it's actually you see more
refugee streams when people get richer
because then they can start afford to
get you know on trucks or buses or even
flights and and go to europe in the u.s
uh but if you're really poor you're just
you know stuck this is more of a moral
problem then i think it's going to be a
first a political problem but i think
fundamentally this is about our
priorities and it's about saying what
kind of moral person do you want do you
want to be the moral person that said i
want to save the world from climate
change so i'm going to make sure we
don't use gas to make fertilizer that
could save millions of people or are you
actually going to be a person who says
no i actually think saving people's
lives is a little more important
but isn't it isn't it even almost worse
right because i think in in many
instances particularly in africa right i
mean it was european politics particular
who who hampered and in some some cases
really sabotaged their ability to feed
themselves right by not allowing them
access to energy i mean if you look at
for example you know global maps about
electricity supplies there is a huge
gap in in most of africa which also
has the highest number of of birth rates
so the population that's growing fastest
is the one with the most limited access
to energy and as you know right whether
it's high temperatures or low
temperatures or whether food production
energy is key and i think in many ways
it was kind of deliberate policies go
kind of the idea that you can all of a
sudden run i don't know you know the
the democratic republic of congo or
these areas that you can run them on
wind and solar so it seems that it's not
just yeah that we don't help them to get
rich if somebody would be a cynic but i
think it's true in some cases we kept
them poor particularly when it came to
energy and food production
i know i i think you're absolutely right
first of all
remember this is a european crisis
that's why we're talking about it if it
was a crisis in africa almost nobody
would care right the second part of this
is that
the reason why africa and many other
places poor is not just because of this
crisis that we're seeing right now it's
much much broader i i
made the comparison last year uh that
all of the energy in uganda which is
bigger nation than than california's
they're like 43 million versus 39
million
all of the electricity in uganda
is less than the electricity
californians used to heat their pools
i also read bjorn that uganda is uh
fertile enough so that if it was
properly harnessed it could feed all of
africa
and that they have a water supply that's
very close to the surface in most of the
country
and that it would be a relatively simple
matter to sink pumps all over the
country to get enough water to produce
the place fertile enough to feed the
entire continent that's just that's just
uganda yeah and and again remember it's
not just about getting food it's about
becoming rich why is it we got rich we
got rich because a hundred years ago so
the average of uh industrial work in the
u.s in the in the last part of the 1800s
used most of most industrial production
was just his work force it was typically
a he uh today is what you know six or
seven percent of the energy that goes in
is actually muscle power the rest of it
we get from fossil fuels mostly from
fossil fuels that's what's made us rich
because we can suddenly do you know 10
times as much uh if you if you translate
the energy that every person has into
what would that be in equivalent human
terms uh each one of us in the rich
world has the equivalent of slaves that
are you know about a hundred slaves that
you know help us on hand and foot
24 7. this is these are the guys who
drivers around the the roads that
deliver us food that gets us heat and
cool uh in our houses and all the other
things that we love and somehow we're
telling the rest of the world you guys
can't have you don't well okay so that's
part of this that's part of this
argument between economists and
biologists malthusian biologists and
maybe malthusian marxist biologists as
well that has been raging for well since
malthus and that idea is that the only
way forward to planetary salvation is to
accept excessive restrictions on
flourishing and growth is that there's
no way the planet can support us if
we're all rich especially if we have
first world living standards and so the
only thing we can do is cut back
dramatically well in the first world but
the problem with that means that if you
cut back the economy so that rich people
get poorer you doom poor people to
starvation that's absolutely clear and
the economists say instead well no look
we can get more bang for the buck
continually we can drive towards an
efficiency that overcomes the malthusian
problem and that would be the problem of
overpopulation let's say and we can we
can have more of what we need for less
cost with less mess
and
and furthermore that the best way out of
environmental catastrophe and wood
burning and indoor pollution and all of
that early life
uh
cessation and high levels of child
mortality all that catastrophe is to
make people rich not poor
and that's such a positive idea it's
like well why wouldn't you aim at that
man we could make especially think about
man you're on the left don't you care
about poor people
well we care about them as long as
they're suffering in a way that boosts
our moral our moral sense of ourselves
but once they start to get rich and have
opinions they're nothing but annoying
i think i think it's right on multiple
levels first of all remember
uh you know there are people there
there's a substantial sort of academic
minority still arguing that we should
have deep growth because of global
warming yeah so they're basically
telling us
we should become less rich especially in
the rich world first of all i think yes
it's a bad idea and we'll get back to
that in a second but also it's just
never going to happen how would you ever
get people to vote for this it's just
impossible to imagine the second part of
it of course is to say do we really
think it's great to let most poor people
stay about the same level as where they
are they talk about maybe they should be
a slight bit better off i think most of
them as you point out want much better
uh than this the third point of course
is as you point out most economists will
tell you we know that when people get
richer
most environmental indicators get much
better people stop cutting down their
forest when they become web designers
instead uh you know they they actually
uh care about the environment and they
pay some of their
newfound richness to make sure that we
pollute less and we have less air
pollution
and as you point out uh indoor air
pollution we stop burning you know
coal or or wood or dung inside our homes
remember this is not a trivial issue
about three billion people cook and keep
warm with really dirty fuels which means
that these three billions 23 million
yeah right die a year because of that
yes and
it's equivalent according to the world
health organization to each one of these
people smoking two packs of cigarettes
every day we have no sense of this you
know it's it's clean inside our homes
but it's not clean inside a very large
minority of the world's population
because they're poor and cook and
and keep warm with indoor air pollution
so we will fix many of these problems
but it is important to say we are not
likely to just fix climate change
because we get richer
so far we've seen as you get richer you
emit more co2 not less co2 so we also
need to fix this but again i think you
you've got to be honest and say you're
never going to fix climate change by
just saying let's all be poor that's
just never going to work and also it's
destructive in all kinds of other ways
well yeah i mean well it's going to make
it worse because if you exaggerate
poverty at the low end of the
distribution and tip people into
desperation they're going to decimate
their environment i mean as soon as
people are starving in any given country
the first thing they do is while they
cut down all the trees and they eat all
the animals well of course that's what
they're going to do and so that's a
complete cataclysmic catastrophe and so
even if
getting wealthier does produce an
increment in co2 production and we can
talk about the consequences of that
making people poorer is going to produce
a way bigger increment in co2 production
and produce all sorts of other
cataclysmic consequences so it's not
like there's an easy one it's not as if
that that if we made people poorer that
would in fact address the co2 problem
because it clearly wouldn't in fact it's
more likely to make it worse i i think
we need to keep those separate it would
make all other environmental indicators
worse who would uh you know decimate the
amazon forest it would decimate a lot of
uh uh animal species and a lot of and
would dramatically drive up air
pollution but it might actually reduce
uh co2 emissions so much of the co2 that
we're worried about is the co2 that will
come from a rich india and a rich uh
africa because they would be emitting
you know sort of ten times as much as
what they're doing today so there is
some sense to this but i think it's
important to say it's incredibly morally
irresponsible it is impossible to
imagine that people are going to say
yeah you know what you've just convinced
me i want to stay poor that's just not
going to happen and
it's a bad way to fix the world uh you
know just sort of morally the right way
to do this of course and and that was
what uh uh ralph also pointed out uh uh
you know that this this really is about
making sure that we invest a lot more
for instance in uh uh researching uh
nuclear or a fusion that we actually get
these technologies that will save us now
it could also be uh you know wind or
solar with lots and lots of batteries
that's not competitive right now uh most
of these things are not competitive
right now but we should invest in
research and development to make sure at
least one of these technologies become
rich and
cheap enough and remember that's how
we've saved all the other issues in the
world if we think back in the 1970s or
60s when we worried about the world
running out of food we didn't save the
world by telling everyone i'm sorry
could you eat a little less and then
we'll send it down to africa and
southeast asia we did it through the
green revolution through science and
technology that basically made every
seed produce twice or three times as
much food per hectare that's how you
save the world through technology and
innovation can i throw in something real
quick though because i think you said so
many important things and particularly
what you mentioned also before i mean
one of the numbers i always find
particularly fascinating is in the 1960s
up to the 1960s great britain had as
many inhabitants as nigeria now nigeria
has three times as many as great britain
so these people need to be fed and what
they need mostly for it and you mention
it right it's going to be innovation
it's going to be access to to more to
higher crop yields and how do you get
this well this brings us a little bit
back to the question of netherlands
right in many ways the netherlands are
the silicon the silicon valley of of
agriculture but if you kind of if you
undermine their agricultural sector
knowledge is going to get lost let me
give you two very quick examples one
from my home country of austria they are
now trying to kind of reopen uh coal
power plants they need to get people out
of retirement because there is nobody
around anymore who knows how to run them
right germany has similar problems in
the nuclear sector it is absolutely
astounding right we had the first
nuclear fission happened in 1938 and the
first nuclear bomb in 1945 that was
seven years nowadays it takes more than
10 years to build a nuclear power plant
because in many ways that knowledge has
been neglected right people companies
don't invest in it students don't study
is because there was no interest in it
and i think this is what we completely
underestimate as a side effect of many
of these environmental issues if you
tell people in the netherlands like
we're going to crack down on agriculture
their agriculture and universities will
have less students will have less
innovation and then we have less ideas
right than to give to these countries
whether it's nigeria or others in order
for them to feed their uh their
populations so this is not just
kind of this is also a war against the
future if you want kind of if you
undermine the conditions for future
innovation you've gone like you're gonna
end up maybe in this malthusian trap of
your own making because you hampered the
one thing that would have allowed you to
get out of it and that would be
innovation and growth yeah well on that
on the dutch farmer front let's say
it seems to me that the people in the
world that you should be most ashamed of
persecuting
might in fact be the dutch farmers
because that little country which is
just a postage stamp which has been
scraped out of the ocean by unbelievable
diligent conscientious effort
is the world's
second
largest exporter of agricultural
products and so to ralph's point these
farmers are stunningly efficient and of
course they do pollute because we don't
do anything perfectly and if you
demolish them which seems to be the
current dutch government's plan
pressured in large part by judicial
decision rather than legislative
decision which is also worth thinking
about then not only do you
what demoralize the very people that you
should be celebrating but you risk
demolishing well the food supply and the
knowledge necessary to farm at that kind
of level of efficiency and so
it's it's at points where
people like the dutch farmers are being
persecuted that makes me think that this
is not just ignorance that there's real
malevolence here too because at some
point you're so damn blind with regards
to your moral pretensions and your
insistence that you're the one that's
saving the world with your foolishness
that you've crossed the line from
someone who just doesn't know what
they're talking about to someone who's
actively inflicting carnage and
catastrophe on the world and i would
think that some of that is
motivated by a kind of deep nihilism
about human existence in general the
idea that we're a cancer on the planet
that the the idea that there are in fact
too many of us and as the president of
greenpeace said in relation to the dutch
farmers he he said something like well
you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs which is really
bloody convenient if you don't happen to
be one of the eggs that's being broken
so
you you've had a lot of resistance to
your work bjorn and i know a lot of
that's rooted in people's ignorance but
what what other motivations do you think
there might be
for
rejecting out of hand the kind of well
you say it's not rocket science it's not
that hard to read your book which is how
to spend 75 billion dollars to make the
world a better place it's actually a
pretty straightforward read and hey it's
published and you can buy it so it's
also not that difficult i mean and
you've faced all this vitriol which is
and that's as someone who's actually
environmentally oriented right because
you basically accept the i
ipcc's prognostications with regards to
climate change and so what let's focus
on this
you talk about the fact that we'll be
less rich in a hundred years assuming
our current rate of economic growth than
we would be if we weren't dumping carbon
into the atmosphere and so you are in
favor of certain approaches that might
be appropriate to amelioration how big a
problem do you think carbon dioxide
accumulation is and what should and what
are we actually doing about it that
works
we'll get back to more with our guests
bjorn lomberg and ralph schoelhammer in
just a moment first we'd like to tell
you about birch gold the united states
met the technical definition of a
recession last month two consecutive
quarters of negative growth americans
are concerned washington mutual lehman
brothers chrysler during the 2007
recession these blue chip stocks all
went down to zero overnight how
confident are you that your savings are
protected it's not too late for you to
take action now throughout history gold
has always been the best hedge against
inflation and birch gold group helps you
hold gold and silver in a tax sheltered
retirement account if you have a 401k or
ira that's underperforming text jordan
to 989898 and learn how to convert that
into precious metals text jordan to
989898 and birch gold will send you a
free information kit on how to diversify
into gold tax-free protect your
hard-earned money take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
text jordan to 989898
[Music]
so
let me just back up and then i'll i'll
answer your question uh i tend to
believe that most people are actually
well intended uh and and so so i i tend
to think that when people are free as
you pointed out in the in the dutch case
uh when they're pursuing a uh a court
case to force the uh the dutch
government if i care about this one
thing that's what i want you to do and i
don't think there's something wrong
about a world where you have you know uh
different ngos and different uh uh sort
of ground uh
uh yeah ngos and and green organizations
working for different things but we need
to recognize that you have to prioritize
all of these things and politicians are
not not normally stupid enough to say i
promise to give jobs to everyone or i
promise nobody will die on the road or i
promise that all kids are gonna get to
university or something like that
because we recognize that would actually
have a huge cost impact if i was forced
by a court to do so but we've somehow
allowed ourselves to make stupid uh
proclamations in the environment space i
promise to you know basically get europe
back to uh pre-human
nature state status that's just
impossible to have i promise to get us
to net zero by fifty that's going to be
happening basically
so and
then i'll i'll answer your question so
there's been a lot of economists looking
at what will be the cost and as as ralph
mentioned uh perhaps the most uh
prominent person was uh uh richard uh uh
no dick nor william nordhouse yes sorry
uh uh who got the nobel prize in 2018
the only uh uh uh climate economist get
the nobel prize exactly for his climate
economics he estimates and this is
broadly validated by many but there are
outlier studies um
that the cost if we do nothing about
climate is
will mean that by the end of the century
we'll be about four percent less rich
than we otherwise would be as you point
out we're likely to be much much richer
for a variety of reasons and hopefully
because we're also smart and don't
actually stop our innovation all that
stuff the u.n estimate that on the sort
of middle of the road path uh which is
sort of a bumbling through as we
normally do
in the world each person on the planet
will be
450 as rich as he or she is today that's
an astounding opportunity that of course
will have lifted out most people out of
poverty will no longer have starvation
it will be a wonderful planet in so many
ways remember most people actually don't
believe this but this is likely where
we're headed with global warming and if
we do nothing about it i'm not
suggesting we should it will instead of
being this 450 percent it will only be
i'm sorry i can't show the difference
it's very very tiny right yeah it's
important to get a sense of proportion
yes climate change is a problem yes it
would be better if we were at 450 rather
than 434 percent but this is not the end
of the world it's important 434
better is that's quite a bit better we
can it's it's important to say
it's it's
percent of what we are today so it's 334
better yes right right fair fair enough
well i am willing to settle for that
yeah and so you know you said that you
think that people are mostly motivated
by
by positive inclinations and i'm
inclined to agree with that but i do
think and i i think we really have to
come to terms with this is that
we are being enticed
into taking the easy moral route forward
so there isn't anything more important
to someone
economically practically socially
biologically than their reputation
because their reputation is a marker of
their deserved standing in the social
community and their viability as a
trading and playing partner and the pro
and the way that you accrue reputation
points is through diligent effort and
generosity fundamentally but you can
game that and you game that by by taking
shortcuts to ethical prowess
when you're when you're offered them in
a tempting manner it's like well instead
of getting up at it i'll give you an
example bjorn this is a good example you
know how i stopped being faced by
protests at universities when i went to
talk there
i have my i hold my talks at eight
o'clock in the morning
yeah and you know why that's funny
because none of the bloody protesters
will haul themselves out of bed to come
and you know
agitate about the
magical super nazi because it's eight in
the morning yeah it is funny but it's
also exactly right it's like well yeah
you're once you shake off your hangover
days you can
haul yourself out of bed by six in the
afternoon
to go and protest and wave a sign about
all the evil people who are destroying
the world but if your commitment
requires getting up in the morning once
well that's a bit too much for you and
so this this enticement of laziness
and it's it's this weird nexus between
narcissism and willful blindness and
ignorance because they they foment and
and reinforce each other and as i said
it's it's just not that hard to read
your book especially if you're you've
devoted your life to saving the
environment and i've done what i could
to
bring hammer and tongs to your theories
because your books are pretty damn
optimistic and i think well could that
possibly be real
and i haven't been able to break well
what i haven't been able to do about
your approach is to think of a better
one
thank you
as error-prone as it might be
because who can do cost-benefit analysis
of course it's like okay
but right right and again uh the the the
amazing things you know the the best
things we can do in the world are not
just you know twice as good they're more
like a hundred times or a thousand times
better than the really dumb things that
we very often do and that's of course
why we feel much more comfortable about
it but if it was just a fact of two sure
you know that could be all kinds of
calculations and stuff but when you're a
thousand times off uh maybe we should
start paying attention on where we could
do good and and it gets back to your
point of of what happened for instance
in holland which was driven by a court
case so if you take politicians on their
words and they'll they'll make a lot of
different promises imagine if people
took them to court for all of those
promises
imagine what would happen when court say
well you've said this so we you have to
spend that much money if you actually
did that for all the different things
politicians have said i think it's
plausible that you would actually have a
total account that would be higher than
the entire national budget quite
possibly by a large amount imagine if we
allow the courts to say oh in this case
you promised this so you got to do that
oh in this case you promised this so you
got to do that imagine if the courts did
all of that and then basically said i'm
sorry you've got to spend all of your
gdp so everybody has to pay you know
close to 100 in taxes and we're going to
pay all of these things that politicians
have promised that's ridiculous and it's
of course terrible this is exactly why
we have politics because politics is
that very hard decision between a lot of
different nice competing things that we
would like we both like to have less
nitrogen deposits we'd like to have
better agriculture we'd also like to
have safer roads and we'd like to have
better schools and all these other
things we can't spend all of the money
you know 10 times over so that's why we
have politicians making these hard and
complicated and not you know satisfying
decisions but we shouldn't allow
ourselves to be run you know into courts
deciding no you have to do this because
you promised it because if they did it
across the whole area we would probably
be you know both bankrupt but also we
would not have that crucial conversation
about where do you want to spend the
next dollar
well we would also seed all the
legislative power that should be
instantiated in the sovereign voice of
the people to judicial overlords which
we seem to be doing at a very rapid rate
that's happening in canada partly
because the legislatures are cowardly
and they devolve decisions to the
judiciary when they shouldn't but also
because the judiciary has become
increasingly activist and is perfectly
willing to put their apocalyptic
nightmare uh
what vision at the pinnacle of the
judicial process hierarchy and to start
ruling in accordance with that instead
of relying on precedent rule of law i
mean in canada now you know you cannot
be appointed a judge unless you swear
fealty essentially to the die
mantra they've they've put they've laid
out what the personal requirements are
that are necessary to be a judge and one
of them is sensitivity to all the racial
etc issues that the dei activists
hypothetically believe are a necessary
priority and the second one is
what would it would say openness to the
importance of social justice issues that
they've actually documented this now in
the steps necessary to become a judge in
canada yeah it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable and these activist judges
do believe that well they're way more
efficient than that noisy parliamentary
process
and and that should scare us that is you
know part of the reason why a lot of
people are protesting uh simply because
you can't have a judiciary or anything
that ends up making promises that will
cost you uh at least a large part of
your fortune
just perhaps uh before i get going
if you look at net zero because i think
in some way uh the dutch thing that
we've seen that we've seen and even the
european uh conversation remember uh uh
uh i believe it was um
i forgot it was a citigroup that
estimated that the total cost for europe
because of the increasing energy prices
is going to be about half a trillion
dollars higher than it normally is over
the last 10 years
which is a huge cost but let's just
remember if europe was actually serious
about their net zero goals which of
course is going to be incredibly hard
which basically means we'll have to give
up most of what's such an idiot
wonderful uh in the world according to
mckinsey study that would cost more than
a trillion dollars so twice as much but
every year for the next 30 years so if
we had courts going in and saying no you
gotta you know cut down your nitrogen
deposit costs that will be
terribly disruptive but it's much much
less than what you could actually
imagine is gonna happen uh if if people
actually take our net zero promises uh
seriously and this is not just for uh uh
for europe you know in the us
it's likely that the cost of net zero by
the uh by mid century would be in the
order of 12 000
per person per year
uh and and people are just not going to
accept that remember if you ask people
most people willing to spend you know
something on climate change typically so
sort of between 25 and 200 dollars
but if you ask them so would you be okay
with spending 10 000
no that's not going to happen and you're
going to have an uprising that's i think
why we need to say well we should be
smart about this but we shouldn't be
spending all of our money on one thing
that's both dumb it's also economically
inefficient but it also leaves all the
other challenges unfixed
right well this is a good time i think
maybe to let you go
it's always a pleasure talking to you
bjorn and a privilege to be able to
bring your thoughts to as wide an
audience as possible because
well we would do a lot better off by
following the guidelines that you and
your teams have produced then by
flailing about in this apocalyptic
idiocy and trying to elevate our moral
status with half measures and and and
dimwittedness and expensive you know all
those trillions of dollars that you're
talking about we got to understand
people that when you pull a half a
trillion dollars out of an economy it's
the poor that you doom doing that
because every economic cost is born most
heavily by the poorest people always
that's like a rule of iron rule of
nature and civilization is that
everything that's expensive hurts the
poor most
and so and i'm pretty tired of of
hearing the environmental activists
sacrifice today's real poor to the
hypothetically thriving poor of their
utopian future it's it's appalling
morally and i don't it's not just
ignorant it's darker than that it's
darker than that as far as i'm concerned
you know we have no right whatsoever to
be telling africans and indians and
chinese for that matter that well you
know we're rich and i don't think we'll
give it up rub rub but you guys you know
you should be looking forward to a lot
less
prosperous future than you might
otherwise be
and there's just absolutely no excuse
for that whatsoever especially when we
know we know
we know that if we help the world's poor
or at least got out of their way while
they're trying to be rich that the
planet would actually be in much better
shape we could have our cake and eat it
too and your work is so signally
important in that regard you know and
well hopefully people will wake up and
and and and pay more attention to the
economists and less attention to the
bloody malthusian biologists so
really good talking to you again bjorn
thanks a lot wonderful to talk to both
of you take care ralph take care of
jordan
all right ralph on to the european
protest front so
do you want to tell people what you've
been up to and why and what you've seen
well over the last couple of years a
couple of actually it started a little
bit earlier but can i was a little bit
in in touch with some of the farmers in
in the netherlands and some of the
people also involved in the protests
over the last couple of weeks and i
think there's a few points that are very
important to make and that tend to get
lost in the entire debate i mean these
protests go back to 2019 so this is kind
of they were a little bit glossed over
due to covet right there were stronger
restrictions on on the rights to
demonstrate so kind of the farmers
didn't really have the opportunity to
voice themselves but there is one thing
that is really important for me to make
absolutely clear
when what i use kind of when i describe
them kind of very often use also the
term working class but i think i really
want also to put it into people's heads
working class is not the same as poor
right many of those farmers in the
netherlands are are economically very
well off but what i mean by working
class is kind of literally the people
who make something work so those are
right can i so right they they are the
backbone in many ways of the of the
dutch economy so you know they are
people that need affordable energy that
that produce then food that is
affordable right so this is kind of what
i what i mean by by the working class
and this is also why there is a lot of
sympathy towards them in the public i
mean there was one poll taken uh i think
it was not 10 days ago so i don't do the
exact numbers there hasn't been a poll
since but currently the so-called farmer
citizens party which is kind of the
political representative of the farmers
has one seat in the dutch parliament if
elections would have taken place i think
it was july 11th they would have risen
up to 20 seats and you know mark ruth's
party would have lost 14 out of 34 seats
so there is sympathy from the dutch for
the farmers and it's not just about the
farming it's more a general sense of
that this is an attack on kind of what
makes us wealthy as a country right this
is kind of we are and there's a lot of
pride for the dutch that they feel in
the agricultural sector and they should
be right you said it before it's a it's
a country the size of a post stamp and
they are an agricultural uh animal
livestock farming superpower it's
outstanding if you look at the research
they do it's kind of what they export in
know-how to kenya to indonesia kind of
what they do positive there but this is
all created domestically in this very
strong agricultural sector so just as a
concluding market is to give you a good
comparison
um forcing 30
of of dutch livestock to to be abandoned
or to to basically disappear is kind of
similar to going to silicon valley and
say so tomorrow you have to close down
30 percent of all startups well silicon
valley would still be there but it
probably would be significantly less
innovative and i said this before this
really my big point is if you start to
handbind to sabotage an industry that is
extremely innovative at some point
they're going to stop innovating because
they're going to say first of all they
try to to kind of ingrain themselves
with the political class to get
exceptions so that they they can
continue farming and they will tell this
is what some dutch farmers told me they
tell their children not to take over you
know yeah farms well this is this is the
thing that we really should be aware of
here in in large part is that i've
watched major companies corporations and
other enterprises collapse and they can
collapse precipitously because what
happens is that when you when you
pressure an industry
all the people that have options leave
and the people who have options are the
most competent people and so if you tell
extremely competent and intelligent and
sophisticated farmers because
high producing farmers are all of those
things practical people with a wide
range of knowledge and technical ability
and mechanical ability and and and
street smarts all of that if you say oh
we're going to make your lifestyle both
uncomfortable and and then fundamentally
unviable they're going to think oh well
guess what i have better things to do
with my time see you later and then you
lose the best people right away and as
soon as you do that because a small
proportion of people are responsible for
almost all the productive effort as soon
as you lose that that uppermost echelon
you lose the whole thing so if we force
30 of silicon valley startups to close
or even 10
all that would happen is all the
entrepreneurs would leave silicon valley
like they're leaving california now for
example they're moving out of california
now to places like tennessee and texas
and florida that happens extremely
quickly you cannot pressure competent
people because they just tell you to
screw off and go do something else and
it's a catastrophe okay so tell me to
what's happening on the ground like how
many
do you have any idea what the true
numbers of people are who are involved
in these protests and are they
mounting are they staying the same are
they shrinking
it's it's still going on i mean i looked
at kind of the most let's say
pessimistic or let's say anti-farmer
news outlets and even they admit that it
has been 25 to 30 000 people right that
the protesters themselves say it's over
40 000 so i think the real number is
going to be in between but there is
again something i think that's very
important for the listeners and the
viewers we're talking about the
netherlands the netherlands are usually
not a country with mass protests right
right ingrained in their political
culture they're very consensus oriented
uh political nation this is why also
they have many parties in parliament
there is always a need for consensus so
for them to go onto the streets and you
know block block streets or the
fishermen have blocked harbors that's a
huge thing for the netherlands so even
if the numbers might don't seem that
impressive the fact that it's happening
really makes a difference so so kind of
if you get the dutch to rise i think the
last time it happened was in 1672 where
by the way then the protesters actually
ate there they're then kind of prime
minister so i mean i'm not promoting
eating prime ministers but this is how
he can
he can also end yeah well this is worth
this is worth stressing i mean in some
ways there isn't a more civilized
country in the world than the
netherlands and i'm saying that having
spent quite a bit of time there and
being a great admirer of the netherlands
but we have to understand is that the
netherlands was taken back from the sea
and that took a lot of effort and a lot
of technological innovation over
centuries and so
the netherlands is a very very well
organized society it's hyper productive
it's extremely peaceful it's consensual
and it's also
extraordinarily free and that's a
tremendous number of paradoxical things
to get right and then farmers are not
only practical people who don't fly off
the handle but it's also very expensive
for them to take their equipment their
heavy equipment and not utilize it
productively and put it on the streets
and so
they're they're and they're not the sort
of people who like they're not hippie
protesters in berkeley in 1968 who have
nothing better to do when they're not
drinking and smoking pot these are
people with very difficult jobs and it's
very expensive of them to take time off
and so
for for dutch to be driven to the point
of protest and then for dutch farmers
specifically to be protesting if you
don't see this as a canary in a coal
mine then you're an idiot you're
willfully blind fundamentally yeah
there's and there's more to it i think
this is so so kind of the the general
conversation reporting talks a lot about
the nitrogen issue right kind of the
environmental part of it but i think
this is something and this is why you
see more and more this all over europe
it's a little bit of a conflagration
that over at least the 90s and early
2000s there was a growing discontent in
the dutch population not just about
about environment environmental issues
and environmental policies but also
about migration kind of all these issues
and this comes now together because
there is i'm not to be very clear i'm
not sure if that is true i mean
definitely some of the farmers also
believe it so i i cannot speak to the
validity of it but it's something that
also raises them emotionally which is
this idea right that a lot of the land
is good that the government kind of
wants to force them off the land take
the land and then use the land to house
uh a migrant so to what extent that is
really true the evidence is mixed so
there have been one or two cases where
these plans are really what these plans
exist but if it's really the main
motivation i have my doubts about this
but the point is and this goes back to
what i said initially there is a sense
in the population that that more and
more the group of people that is the
most important to keep the economy going
to keep the country going that also
preserves the culture and these kind of
things that they're constantly under
attack and undermined by the political
and particularly also by the cultural
elite and i think this is this is part
of the story of that anger that should
not be underestimated so this is not
purely because many of my critics said
oh ralph you know this is just about
nitrogen and that comes from the eu yes
that was kind of the straw that broke
the camel's back but there is more going
on underneath well
well what we could say in regard to that
and i would say this is a reasonable
approach from a psychological
perspective is that when you start to
use compulsion on people so compulsion
is the sign of bad policy and so when
you start to use compulsion the the
judiciary compels the legislative branch
and then the legislative branch compels
the farmers forces them
well as soon as you use force on people
you undermine trust
by definition right because you don't
need to use force on people where
there's mutual consensus and trust so
use force and then you elicit
paranoid reactions it's like if you're
going to operate in relationship to me
as a tyrant
then just what sort of tyrant are you
and just exactly what you're up to what
are you up to and so that promotes the
spread of these more conspiratorial
ideas that might have a toehold in the
truth on some fronts but it's it's part
of a sign of a broader breakdown of
communication and trust in society and
that's that's an absolute catastrophe
because
you got to understand this people have
to understand this a guy named landis
wrote a great book called the wealth and
poverty of nations about this very
factor he basically claimed and i think
with plenty justification that the only
real natural resource is trust
and that it's it's it almost requires a
metaphysical miracle to set up a country
where the default response from one
stranger to another is well of course i
can shop in your store and you're not
going to rip me off of course i can buy
something online and i'm going to get
the product of course i can send my kids
to schools that the government runs and
that'll be fine it's just a matter of
course that's a miracle and when you use
compulsion in the service of an
apocalyptic ideal and undermine that
trust then you generate all sorts of
well an endless amount of conspiratorial
thinking and and that's a catastrophe
no i think you touch on something that's
extremely important and that is because
when particular in the trust issue
increasingly and this i would argue by
the way happens all over the west that
is not just a dutch phenomenon right
that the the the quote-unquote working
class and if you want to call them the
ruling class we can quibble about this
but they increasingly inhabit completely
different moral universes right they
live in completely different worlds
exactly what you said right the the the
people as i call them right the working
people they want you know they want
affordable energy they want good public
schools they want to maintain their
cultural and political identity all
these things and then you have the the
political class the academia class and
they have different goals right for them
climate change is number one right for
them you know social justice is number
one but it's simply not the same for
these other people and you at some point
you cannot have both of these competing
moral priorities in the same country
like it will come to a head sooner or
later and i think this is what we see in
europe and to be honest i think this is
just the beginning right because these
these ground swells have been there but
as long as the economy was more or less
working okay as long as people felt that
by the end of the year they were better
off than the year before they were
tolerating you know the the eccentricies
of their elites right they said well
those are those accounts in the
universities and now we all know how
politicians lie but as long as i have
access to a better longer things are
working exactly but once they stop
working and this is so important what
you said because the true test of trust
is a crisis so all these polls whether
in the in the past where they said oh
these are such high trust societies well
they were high trust when things were
going well but now we'll see how well
developed the trust really is if in in
in the fall the worst of the crisis is
really gonna hit and i'm not that
optimistic yeah and so what do you what
do you foresee in the fall or are you in
a position to comment on that well it
depends of course a little bit on what
we talked originally on the way that
russia is going to behave but we already
see things happening right we see for
example the government in italy imploded
then we have like very small things now
in austria when the austrian president
right he's not a famous figure or
anything but kind of when he goes to
public appearances right that that
people are booing him and these are
these are things that didn't happen in
the past it's happening in canada too
yeah so this is that is this this
content is real and what what kind of
worries me the most is that
the the politics doesn't have an answer
to it right they immediately revert they
do it in italy now they do it in
australia whatever they do it also in
the dutch case they immediately revert
to their preconceived notions right all
those are all you know right wing uh
kovitz denying
misogynistic misogynist
what justin trudeau said i mean yeah i'm
sure these people exist in that group as
well but the thing is um you just
increase the anger if you don't at some
point approach them and say okay so what
bothers you what ails you and just kind
of to put something to this i think a
little bit this revolution started in
2016 with the election of donald trump
and what i mean by this is they did a
fantastic standing study at the rant
institution where they said what's the
best way to predict whether or not
somebody was voting for donald trump you
know is it race is it is it skin color
is it you know income it turned out the
best way to predict is that those people
who crossed on the questionnaire i feel
that i have no voice i feel that i'm not
seen that was the best predictor for
people to vote for donald trump and
that's not gonna stop
yeah well people believe that trump
addressed them
if idiosyncratically and eccentrically
and even narcissistically at least
directly
honestly and in an unscripted manner and
trump was very good at well that's the
populist danger that the leftists point
to is that trump could and did to some
degree appeal to resentment and that's
very dangerous especially for a
conservative um i think he was also
pushed into a corner on that
on that front because he was pilloried
so badly that it's not surprising that
he regarded himself as surrounded by
enemies right and you can create a
monster by persecuting someone intently
and i'm saying that as someone who i
think is cognizant and appreciative of
whatever donald trump's flaws might be
but it's definitely the case that the
working class felt that they had been
shunted out of the conversation and the
reason they felt that way was because
they had been shunted out of the
conversation
and it's certainly the case
if that wasn't true
in some fundamental sense hey you
wouldn't have seen the trucker protest
in canada the corresponding protests in
the u.s and now the spread of this into
europe right you can't just put that at
trump's feet by any stretch of the
imagination and so
so what do the farmers want and what's
the probability that they're going to
get it and what do you think is going to
happen next well in fact i would argue
that that demands are very reasonable
right because if you look at the numbers
they have been very successful in
reducing uh emissions over the last
couple of years so we mentioned this
before really dutch agriculture is is
astounding it's i would argue it's one
of the innovative wonders of the world
and they mostly they mostly complain
about the timeline so again it's not
that they say no we want to continue to
emit as much as possible no they just
say that 2030 2035 and 2050 is not
feasible for us we can't do it in the
timeline and the argument that comes
back is well but you know these are
these are you know eu regulations well
that is true but yeah whatever exactly
and it's something that beyond that also
before well of course they have more
nitrogen emissions they are they are the
number one agricultural producing
country in europe so so i mean it's kind
of natural that they have more emissions
and they did have an exception for a
long time and they pretty much only want
that exception to continue well the
other thing is that there isn't anybody
who care who cares more about long-term
sustainability than actual farmers
because a lot of those people well not
only do they want to farm for decades
which is a much longer time span horizon
than most politicians and most people
but a lot of them would like to be able
to have their children do the same thing
and they don't want to degrade the
topsoil and they don't want to pollute
the water and and so but they want to
produce as much food as they possibly
can and you're not going to do that
without some waste i mean that's the
thing about these net zero
policies you know as soon as someone
talks talks about zero anything that
there's a totalitarian bent to them
because the cost of getting to actual
zero is absolutely disproportionate like
you could think well how about a how
about an eighty percent reduction it's
like okay we might be able to manage
that well how about 90 well you're
pushing it well there's an exponential
increase in the cost of getting from 90
to 95 and then again from 95 to zero and
so zero is nothing but moral posturing
and so
and so what's happening outside of
holland how outside of the netherlands
how cognizant are you of the nature of
the spread of these protests into
germany and to italy and into
and into spain you know that the
canadian government collapsed in some
sense under the weight of the trucker
convoy it wasn't the federal government
but the conservative party leader
resigned and the conservatives imploded
which was
unfortunate in the highest degree
although we might get a better leader
out of the deal and so these protests do
have a tremendous amount of significance
so okay so what's happening on this on
the protest spread front there's there's
a couple of things currently that happen
parallel i mean i sometimes like to
compare it a little bit to the arab
spring and the reason why i use this
comparison is not because of the
dimension of the protesters at the
moment they are not nowhere near but
what you also mentioned it's kind of how
these things can become contagious right
in in the in the arab spring he started
in tunisia with a vegetable vendor you
know but kind of put up basically
burning himself alive and then kind of
this this spread throughout the entire
middle east and what you see in in
europe increasingly happen is so we have
to the dutch case we had some protests
in spain um basically emmanuel macron's
government in france is is a lame duck
now they really can't get anything done
uh the kind of the the amount of trust
that the people or the distrusted people
expressed towards him in the last
elections i think it's only a matter of
time until you're probably also going to
see protests in france you see it
partially also in eastern europe right
there are protests in in poland uh there
have been protests in italy that did
play a role in the in the downfall of
the current government it's going on a
little bit in spain which by the way has
huge political repercussions as you
probably have heard right talking about
the gas crisis so the european
commission says every european country
needs to reduce their gas consumption by
and the first countries who said we're
not going to do this were among others
were spain and italy because they know
how fragile their systems are they can't
and this is the thing we live in a
situation where western governments not
all of them but many they no longer can
really ask sacrifices of their people
because the people say no you know what
you also first of all they don't lead by
example we don't have you know
austere shall the goal like politicians
and personality i would argue matters in
this way right it really matters who
asks you for a sacrifice and they don't
even really ask for sacrifice they kind
of demand it right because you have to
that's the yeah yeah so you have to
reduce your your your energy use and of
course people yeah or else
will punish you yeah or else and this is
this is and the other important thing
for them germany is the best example
here that people say but wait a moment
you told us you got this under control
you told us we can close down over the
last two years you know six nuclear
power plants so three have been closed
down another three will be closed down
in december not going to be a problem
right so insane yeah right so they they
were told i'm always very careful to use
the word lie because i like to believe
in the best of people but they were
definitely told things that turned out
to be entirely to be entirely untrue now
they're not just untrue you know they're
i've been thinking about the
distinctions between different different
forms of untruth and so
if you're a a canny liar and maybe even
a moral liar when you lie your
your lie is an approximation to the
truth it's just bent in a slight
direction but
if you're really hell-bent on lying you
tell anti-truths and the idea that we
could close down nuclear plants in
germany
and replace that with stable and
reliable
renewables that that would benefit the
planet and that that wouldn't come at a
unsustainable economic and political
risk which has clearly been the case
that was an anti-truth it wasn't just a
lie and i don't think it's mere
ignorance because
like i'm not a political expert
by profession let's say
and it was obvious to me 10 years ago
that
producing hyper reliance on russia
was just not a good idea
it just exposed the west to too much
risk
and i can't see how you could be a
political leader
look you're going to be pessimistic
about this one way or another if you're
blind enough as a political leader not
to see that as a stark reality you're
way too blind to be a political leader
and if you're malevolent and malicious
enough to manipulate that for your own
personal and political gain then you're
too nefarious to be a political leader
and if you're both well then well then
you have the kind of leaders that we do
have unfortunately at the moment in many
situations and i would certainly rank
our current prime minister as first and
foremost among those the poster boy of
the wef and the globalist utopians and
he's bent and demented this poor country
of mine in ways that canadians are just
barely beginning to wake up to
i mean i think there's there's more to
it i mean you i think you in your
writings and also your commentary you
touch on this again and again which i
think is so important i mean this is
also a a little bit an element of of a
civilization in in a crisis but also a
crisis of confidence i mean take one
example i always find this so
fascinating the the hoover dam right was
built in five years during a great
depression the golden gate bridge was
built in four years during the great
depression nowadays if you want to build
something in the united states right you
have to wait up to five years to get the
environmental impact study i mean why
would anybody try to build anything like
that so and i'm not sure at some point
could we still do it if we wanted to no
we we couldn't well look you know i just
reached out to buda jig's office a
couple of weeks ago about the
immense spending that's occurring on the
infrastructure front
and because some of the people that i've
been involved in had a hand in that
assuming that the democrats who are
going to spend a lot of money might
might spend it on something useful like
fixing bridges let's say because
infrastructure spending has about a 13
to one return on investment that seems
to be the calculation
and then so we reached out to budajig's
office and tried to get some figures
it's like okay you guys have all this
money
do you have a website
that you where you've listed the
projects that the money is being spent
on and just are tracking whether or not
anything's actually happening and the
deputy secretary wrote back he reached
out to an infrastructure expert that i
was in contact with and and and and
encouraging to ask this question and he
said
well we're not sure that
on a project of this scale that
effectiveness
genuinely in quotes effectiveness is a
realistic goal and we don't believe that
something with this sort of widespread
significance can be evaluated
essentially at that level of granularity
and then he sent me a map that showed
how much money had been given to each
state
which is not the question i asked it's
like i don't give a damn how much money
you spent
that's easy
my business partner always laughed with
me said it's really easy to grow your
business on the cost side and and the
amount of money you spend is not an
indicator of your moral
advantage or your moral reliability
what you've produced as a consequence of
the spending is and as far as i can tell
on the democrat side
there's no
care whatsoever given
to actually seeing whether the
infrastructure money can be spent now
when i talked this through with many of
the moderate democrats i'm in contact
with
we became painfully aware that the
infrastructure bill spending was going
to be in trouble because there are so
many regulations and so much red tape
that it's not even necessarily the case
that much of this repair can in fact be
done
and i thought for a long time
if we invented automobiles
mobiles today no one would be allowed to
drive one too dangerous too polluting
you just wouldn't have the freedom
there's no way the americans could build
the interstate highway system now and
these big projects of the sort that
you're describing i don't think we have
the will anymore or the ability to do
them because we've tangled ourselves up
in moral quagmires i would i would i
would go a step further if if coffee you
know alcohol and tea would be discovered
today you would never find it in the
shelves in the supermarket because it
would seem to be way too dangerous and
that's that's the thing we are we are we
are becoming increasingly good in
regulating like you know if you take new
york under mayor bloomberg right we can
regulate the the salt and the sugar out
of your coke and your cheeseburger but
we can no longer build a new bridge
right we can no longer actually build an
efficient like a highway system as it
was built in the 1960s i really think we
can no longer do this we can if you
forgive that expression we can torment
the the average person with ever-growing
regulations at the same time however
create conditions that those on top
escape those regulations i mean why do
you think that the average american bill
and it's the same in in europe as well
has you know 500 pages because it's
basically a list of exceptions so the
only person that actually is going to
suffer or be affected by that bill is
going to be you know the small family
company or or you know the small
there was this great example a couple of
years back about a hardware store in
california and and what they did is
right kind of you mentioned before so
people that came early you know at eight
o'clock they handed out coffee and
donuts so they put up a box a box of
donuts and a and a can of coffee
the state of california was harassing
them without end because they need a
permit do they have a kitchen are they
up to uh to that you know hygiene
standards until the hardware owner said
you know what i wanted to do something
nice for my for my customers i no longer
do it so it's so in this area the state
is extremely powerful but when it comes
to other issues they're extremely weak
and this is going to be this is going to
be a problem again i think for all of
western uh if you forgive the expression
for all of western civilization if we
don't kind of get our stamina back if we
kind of don't return to the spirit and
and as well the the capacity to get
things done we have a problem and that i
think is the thing is with the dutch
farmers right they say wait a minute we
actually do something we produce
something we are the best in you know
potato which is the case right we have
the highest yield peaker worldwide in
tomatoes the highest yeah they should be
getting prizes for that right i mean
these people should be getting awards
you should find the person who has the
highest potato yield per unit of
fertilizer used and and give him i don't
know what the equivalent of the order of
canada is in the netherlands but
obviously that's a person who's a who's
a hero in every sense of the word
and and what's also so surprising to me
and that tends to tilt me towards a
certain degree of
perhaps on warranted cynicism is that
it's the very people who trumpet their
allegiance to the working class and the
oppressed who are at the forefront of
targeting these excellent avatars of of
the working class defined the way you
defined it which is well those are the
people who like
work
and so why don't you leave them alone or
at least get the hell out of their way
no i would i would even go a step
further we kind of live in a in a kind
of reverse marxism at the moment where
the working class wants to defend
industrialization and the the ruling
class right those who have capital the
jeff bezos and others and nothing
against them personally but they promote
de-industrialization so it's really it's
a complete reversal of of what we would
think right that the exploited working
class will will they will storm the
factories and the machines it's the
other way around they want to keep the
machines and just to give another
example germany like villarreal and
bosch right they make tiles in germany
like a traditional company they have
been producing in germany since 1879
they closed down production and moved to
to turkey they said we can no longer
afford with uh labor costs energy costs
it's impossible for us to produce there
but a huge majority of those costs comes
from regulation right if there was there
was this case last example but i think
this was so telling during the economic
crisis of 2008 2010 right whether the
workers in factory said we know this is
a hard time so we are willing you know
to put in the extra hour we want to see
our company remain to be sustained to
succeed and what happened was that the
federal union sued the workers who
voluntarily wanted to continue to work
so this is kind of these are all these
cases where we continue to shoot
ourselves in our own foot and that is no
longer sustainable at some point and i
think this is what the people in europe
feel let me give you one last statistic
if you're a 15 year old italian now the
the expected work life you're going to
have is 35 years i mean that's very much
in the lower end for when for the
inventor markets 42 for australia it's
38 but the point is if you imagine so we
get about you know life expectancies
around 80. out of those 80 years we're
gonna work for let's say 35 years this
is not sustainable under current
conditions and
what i believe is is and this is going
to be the great unknown which is why i
cannot tell you exactly what's going to
happen
so far in europe we haven't seen a
politician capable of channeling that
anger right of giving a voice to that
anger so
whether it's a trumpet figure or
whatever you would call it so we haven't
seen that but i think the potential is
there so if you have a politician i
believe that would stand up and say
listen
i cannot promise you to uh you know
retire at 65 and go to university until
you know 42.
these are gonna be hard times but what i
can guarantee you is that i will fight
tooth and nail for affordable energy for
good public schools for controlling
immigration right and i can elite by
example i am convinced that such a
politician
would have tremendous potential but we
are in this situation
where all the potential new politicians
come out of the same bubble where the
previous politicians were you know
created so i don't think they see it yet
which is again going back to 2016 which
is why for all his absurdities and i
think he grasped it more instinctively
than strategically donald trump was
successful when he was absurd but he was
authentic he spoke to something he spoke
to anger that people felt and we have
very good numbers for example the
election in virginia in the fall last
year he mobilizes people that have never
gone to the voting booth in their entire
life right and then this gold toilet
possessing you know too long thai
wearing guy comes along and
rural virginia voters say yep that's the
guy i'm gonna give my vote for and and i
think we know why that's the case yeah
well there's a real opportunity on the
both the classic liberal and the small c
conservative front right now to make a
compelling case for the genuine working
class and to say you know we
admire your thrift and competence and
diligence and conscientiousness we
admire your
willingness to make sacrifices for your
children we want you to be richer if
you're doing so by being productive and
generous we support all that
full
in a full-fledged and wholehearted
manner we don't want you to be guilty
about that because you're bringing
wealth the wealth to the world that
stops people from dying from absolute
privation and destroying the environment
while doing so and all of that's just
lying on the table for
someone who isn't a populist and just
appealing to resentment to carry forward
and you know maybe that could happen
we're trying to hatch plans on that
front in a variety of
on a variety of in a variety of manners
at the moment
and so but i am very very nervous about
the upcoming winter especially because
the russians not especially but in part
because the russians have the control of
the taps to germany and if i was putin
and pushed into a corner i wouldn't
hesitate to use that for a second that's
a much preferable alternative to nuclear
weapons and also one that's much more
morally justifiable
not that it's morally justifiable but
it's more morally justifiable and it's
not like he doesn't have
devastating economic weapons at his
disposal
no i think i think you're right i mean
this is exactly the point that you know
many people now talk in the in the
pundit class about the decolonization at
the breakup of the russian federation
and and what are we going to do once
this with russia once this war is over
i'm more concerned about the european
union i'm not sure if exactly what you
described uh i'm not sure if the if if
the worst should happen right can if the
worst case scenario will kind of
complete gas stop right you know break
down of the industry do things this the
the european union is not going to
survive this yeah so um on the european
union front you said that there's lots
of pundits who
are prognosticating the breakup of the
russian federation saying the demise of
the putin administration but there's
every bit of evidence to suggest that
the first thing to crack and break might
be the european union i italy and greece
and spain can't tolerate the economic
pressure especially if things start to
go sideways
then one thing that you mentioned at the
beginning right kendall was the worst
case scenarios for the fall particularly
in relation to russian gas and i think
this is what we see now unfolding is
that the unity of europe is not as much
as we thought it was
they could kick down the can down the
road
with the economic crisis because the ecb
could just print money so you kind of
could gloss over the potential problems
and effects for a majority of the people
but if russia is really you know
reducing gas to zero right we we talk
about jobs lost in industry people
unable to heat their homes
we talk about
you know repercussions that will will
have effects on on every single person
living within the european union and
then countries will immediately to start
to look for alternatives which we
already see like spain has said we have
uh you know lng uh ports we can import
liquid liquefied natural gas we're gonna
do this and we're gonna use it for the
spanish people another quick example the
foreign minister minister of hungary
right
i think otherwise a very impressive man
just two days ago traveled to to moscow
and met with the russian foreign
minister lavrov in order to ensure that
hungary will continue to get gas now
currently he's very much scolded which i
understand but the thing is
what hungary is doing sooner or later
other countries will follow suit and by
the way most european countries still
export tons of fossil fuels from coal to
oil to gas from russia so if they really
cut it to zero or significantly restrict
it i think that that is a lethal threat
to the to the european union and to the
european project and the fact that this
is barely talked about i find very
disconcerting
yeah well i it's i think the reason it's
barely talked about is because it's the
logical inevitable consequence of this
idiot moral posturing that's been going
on for 15 years and it is indicative of
a degree of blindness that is almost
miraculous in its totality
i mean how in the world could you
possibly think that making your energy
grid non-resilient and then relying on
the russians was a reasonable move
forward and this is independent in some
sense of whether you have good relations
with the russians and how could you
possibly think that making energy more
expensive was going to be good for the
planet when it devastates poor people
especially when you're also purporting
to care above all for the poor and
oppressed like this is so utterly
preposterous and so backwards that it
could it couldn't in some ways it
couldn't be
we couldn't be doing more damage to
ourselves
in some sense if we were trying and you
know bjorn just sort of casually
mentioned and i this is no slur on bjorn
that's for sure but it was an aside that
well it's probably a billion
1.2 billion people that are going to be
going hungry this fall it's like
what
what in a world where
there could be enough food to make
everyone fat as we've seen happening
over the last two decades we're actually
going to enter a period where mass
starvation is a thing again
and so
and we're doing that because we're we're
being moral and we're trying to save the
planet that that's really that's really
what you think that's really how you
think the evidence is laying itself out
well obviously the dutch farmers and
these sensible working-class types they
know that something's up they know that
the jig is up you know and i don't know
if you know this but these protests are
receiving almost no coverage in places
like canada our national newscaster just
won't talk about it at all and it's
because they know i think in some real
sense that this is the death knoll for
the utopian globalist agenda and this is
happening the same week that trudeau has
announced that he's going to force the
farmers because he likes force because
of course he's saving the planet and
forces justifiable he's going to force
the canadian farmers into exactly the
same conundrum that he's
that the dutch government is forcing the
dutch farmers into and you know i know
farmers in canada and they're not the
backwoods rubes that intellectual elites
like to presume they are these people
use satellite technology they know to
the square foot where the fertilizer in
their land is going they're really
motivated to reduce fertilizer use
because it's expensive and so they want
to target it as carefully as possible
but instead of working with them and
talking with them and meeting with them
with a degree of respect that's clearly
earned and deserved the government just
says well you guys could be doing a
better job it's like well
we're doing the best job of anybody in
the world
and that's particularly true in holland
but you know canada would be a close
well it'd be in the top 10.
this is i think you know i think the
point you made i mean there's one thing
we probably have to keep this for
another day but i think that's something
that also needs more to discuss we have
a problem here and i think this is from
which this all flows in the educational
system as well it's a
in you know you know in academia but
also also already in school right kind
of we we we can start to marinate young
people in a sense of of not just a
rejection of of modernity but also in
the sense of historical self-hate and i
think this is the problem so there is
sometimes i feel and we touched upon
this a little bit with bjorn as well but
i really feel sometimes there is this
idea is particularly strong in germany
because the germans always have a thing
for ideology but it's it's a
particularly strong sense
and yes right and this is exactly the
thing now i think that they say you know
we're gonna we're gonna atone for our
past and we're gonna sacrifice the
future for it right so so at some sense
that the pain is not a bug but it's a
feature right now that you're i'm
exaggerating here for dramatic effect
but it is you know now we suffer so
now we can atone for our sins of of the
past and
you know you know you you can do this
but as i said it's probably gonna cost
you at some point your future well
that's self-flagella that
self-flagellation instead of proper
atonement and proper atonement is well
we're going to take stock of the
catastrophes of the past and our
oppressive use of power and we're going
to do better and i mean part of the
thing that i've been trying to do while
i've been touring around is asking
people individuals to try to do better
because that's the best thing to do is
to bear your responsibility and
to bear your privilege too you know is
that we are privileged here in the west
and the way we atone for that is by
being
people whose lives justify
our provision of resources and our
god-given talents and that's the only
way forward and these false sacrifices
they're for show they're like praying in
public to use a gospel uh metaphor it's
like well don't pray in public just
get your life together and be productive
and generous and kind and work towards
life more abundant and stop elevating
your moral status inappropriately with
your blind ignorance and your moral
pretensions especially at the cost of
the actual poor which is what we're
doing now no
allow me to make one last point on this
because exactly what you said right this
is maybe why we should should i know
that you're also a huge fan of russian
literature right why people should read
particularly in this in this respect
tolstoy again i think i think we need to
allow people and i think this is what
the working class wants but you can find
satisfaction you can find a fulfilling
life in being you know being a farmer uh
being a good husband you know being a
being a mother all these kind of things
it doesn't always have to be saving the
world i mean also psychologically i mean
we take 18 year olds and that is how you
save the world precisely right one one
community at a time but now we take 18
year olds uh and we we tell them you
know the world is gonna end the only
people who can change it is you uh no
wonder that we have you know such high
degrees of of attempted suicide and and
depression and these kind of things i
think what we're doing to to young
people as well as a consequence of this
well and we're telling them that not
only can they
can they
change the world but they're and save
the world but they should do it now that
they're wiser than their elders which
they definitely are not
and and that the best way to change the
world and to save it is by stopping the
bad people from doing what they're doing
and so it's a pandering it's a pandering
of the worst sort and it's certainly the
case that the intellectual class bears
first and foremost the responsibility
for that occurring and it's it's also
sometimes it also has almost a
ridiculous i i find element if you think
about then again i hold no grudge
against against greater toonberg i think
you know that that she has achieved
quite a lot but if you saw these
pictures at the u.n and other meetings
right where were mostly men in their in
their mid 50s were you know kind of
fawning over her and they wanted
pictures taken with her
i i just think you know that for me is
not serious right i mean if again as you
said with baron right i mean talk to the
scientists talk to the people at actual
solutions but don't look for it for you
know a good photo op right i mean again
i i like krita timber i like arnold
schwarzenegger i like all these people
but
i'm not entirely sure to what extent i
would take my moral cues from them well
certainly not at a practical level you
know i mean these problems are extremely
difficult you know if you want to do
something like build a more effective
sewage plant and who wouldn't want that
then you talk to the engineers who know
how to build sewage plants these things
have to be brought down to the level of
painstaking detail and that requires a
lot of time and effort like the time and
effort the democrats would have had to
put in for example to track their
infrastructure spending
right and that's that's something you do
if you're knowledgeable and you've done
a bathroom renovation and you know how a
construction project can get out of
control instantly and doesn't if you're
not paying attention to every detail and
the working class people they're the
ones who are paying attention to the
details right they're making sure that
their laces are tied and that the rubber
hits the road and that the vehicles are
maintained and they have that pragmatic
knowledge of how the world works that
the elite use when they fly off into
their into their utopian towers of babel
so well ralph we should probably call it
a day
i guess um that was a good discussion
and um
congratulations on the work you've been
doing it's extremely important thank you
so much i hope that i hope that this
helps you bring
your coverage of the
emerging european protest scene to a
much broader audience and helps clue
people into the fact that these are not
simple misogynists and racists and
bigots as they were described in canada
but unbelievably sophisticated
hard-working and people who have
excellent businesses in the highest
sense who have been driven to
desperation by the idiot machinations of
their utopian masters so
really good to meet you and i hope we
get a chance to meet in person
you